here are the biggest updates that have
come to cyberpunk 2077 in 2023 namely
with the 2.0 update this is stuff that
does not come with Phantom Liberty so
this is all free the first one is
updates to skills and perks skill trees
are now much more intuitive there are
also plenty of new perks and skills that
you can choose from and the whole thing
is organized sort of more succinctly to
help you really specify what kind of
build you want where previously it was
like a bit messy cyberware which is one
of the coolest parts of the game has
also had an overhaul there are
essentially a whole bunch more options
and a lot of them are very fun I feel
like this and the perks and skills
updates make it feel more like an RPG
like you're playing a really specific
kind of character vehicular combat has
also had a big upgrade and that you can
now engage in combat while driving there
are also new weapons and tools for
vehicular combat combat and AI Behavior
overall have had improvements
essentially the AI now behaves more
realistically in combat it was certainly
a big thing that was getting memed
police will now actually chase you when
you commit a crime which previously they
didn't do because they were worried it
would be annoying but it certainly
seemed to turn a lot of players off
types of Pursuits are based on your
wanted level a lot more like GTA